Luke dominate here with the outdoor boys
YouTube channel today we're catching
cleaning and cooking baby deer you guys
excited yeah hey guys welcome to another
episode of the outdoor boys YouTube
channel today we are in the rocky
mountains and we're gonna be doing some
primitive hunting trapping and cooking
hope you guys are excited cuz this is
gonna be an awesome video you guys ready
yeah first off I'm going to show you how
to build a primitive snare and we're
gonna do that with just some basic tools
here first we've got select a nice
stretchy willowy tree here
that is that helping you get all these
branches off alright we've got a nice
thick branch here now let's go find
ourselves a trigger okay now you're
gonna find yourself a fork stick you
want a pretty decent one and we're gonna
sharpen this in well carve this to a
point right about here so once you've
got this carved gonna put a notch right
about here there we go got a nice little
notch carved in right there nice and
pointy here sharpened down here we're
ready for the next part alright guys so
here's the trigger we got a flat and
sharp on one point then long skinny
point on the other okay let me show you
how this trigger mechanism works you
take this pointy side down shove it into
the ground really good you take this
trigger and you balance it right there
and then you put your meat or bait right
there and you have a string attached to
a noose or a snare like this when
something sticks its head in here in a
munch with the bait they stick their
head through the news and they bump it
and flink this flies up in the air
tightens the noose around their neck you
found this great little spot where deer
have been pawing the way eating roots or
berries or something like that so we're
gonna build a deer trap and I'm going to
show you guys how to trap and snare deer
then
hopefully we'll catch one and do a
little catch and cook video for you too
as well you do that go for it I've got
this long flexible sapling here and I'm
gonna put it in the ground as hard as I
can get it nice and anchored here to
make the snare I'm going to use
monofilament not the best thing to use
but it's what I've got some forty pound
mono here so what I'm gonna do is we're
going to take a length of this and tie
it from the sapling to the trigger and
then I'm going to take another little
bit and make a slipknot news that's
going to be right there by the trigger
you see here these little sticks keep
the noose open around the trigger and
you put the bait on the trigger or
something touches the trigger weak the
stick gets caught in the snare and the
trigger is up here and it just chokes
the animal even if it doesn't lift them
off the ground it just chokes them now
we're gonna get the trap baited up and
set for real and we used one of my
favorite baits as far as bait goes
nothing beats pizza you put this in your
trap and it's gonna get triggered faster
than the snowflake alright guys so let
me show you the trap here alright guys
so there's a trap album we're gonna let
this sit for a little bit while we go
bear hunting now I'm gonna put a GoPro
camera on this trap so we can see if
anything gets caught in the trap okay
alright guys so we've got the trap set
should we go hunting now yeah alright we
need to go make weapons to hunt animals
you know should we go make weapons
who wants a spear alright we should go
make some Spears you're gonna blow the
bubbles at the animals eyeballs yeah
good I'm glad you guys brought bubbles
then
all right there we go got my spear tip
all right neat this will be your spear
here it's attracting the Bears and hawks
well we wait for an animal to get in our
trap
what should we go hunting for so if
we're gonna hunt bear we need bear bait
who's gonna be the bear bait not me
okay Nathan's the bear bait so now this
will be fun this is the fun part and to
help enhance the flavour of Nathan when
we use them as bear bait we're gonna rub
him in pepperoni pizza just rub the
pizza into the boys face as much as you
can really helps enhance the flavor of
children you feel tasty Nathan yeah all
right you guys ready to go hunt bears
let's go let's go hunt bear this way
let's go hiking we'll hunt some bears
and then we'll go check our trap all
right Tom you got your spear keep an eye
out for bears or raccoon will spear a
raccoon
brown bear would be awesome how many
miles have we've been hiking oh wait
guys come here come here get down come
over here good job wait I think I hear
something be very quiet
[Music]
wolf is dead be very quiet I think daddy
here's something here's something listen
you hear it I must have been the Bears
doing that maybe a bear over here in
this valley maybe we should throw rocks
down there and see if any bears move
should I throw my spear down there do I
get a bear Oh got one did I get a bear
yeah I don't know if I want to bear that
bad yeah I don't want to go down there
yeah I walk it down there
you Steve this should be my new spear
okay let's see oh yeah this is big
enough for daddy
see how far I could throw this spear up
too bad that's my spear the tree dad can
throw his spear whoo good throw there
bud all right let's go back and check
the trap see you if we caught anything
oh just another 10 miles or so hey guys
I think I see something I think the trap
sprung let's go check it out
what is it oh man look at this oh yeah
yeah that worked like a charm we're look
at that right around the neck right
where it should be
oh wait hey I think he's still alive
hold on yeah there we go let's take him
home and cook him alright guys we're
back here at the cabin and I'm gonna
show you how to gut and prepare baby
deer now fawn is an absolute treat it's
it's a delicacy in most parts of the
country and so here is no exception
and when you want to prepare succulent
baby deer you want to open the chest
cavity and cool off the carcass as
quickly as possible now I know YouTube's
got some weird rules about showing us
killing animals so I'm gonna go ahead
and just talk you through it
and try to try to avoid anything too
graphic here but we're gonna take this
buck 110 I'm gonna shove it right here
into the chest cavity we're gonna work
our way from the throat all the way to
the anus right there and oh look this is
this right here this the organs on a
baby deer are the best look at that you
want some yeah enjoy that yeah yeah look
at that let me let me get into the chest
cavity here oh yeah look at this yes
this right here is why you eat baby deer
that is delicious stuff right there here
don't you have some of that I'm gonna
tell you you can you can fry it you can
smoke it make sausages out of it but
probably the best way to eat baby deer
is just fresh you know mm-hmm sashimi
style don't look in there it's really
gross Nathan oh good there are some more
I've got some lungs here oh good guys
what does it taste like tastes like
cotton candy that's right
baby deers fart rainbows and they taste
like cotton candy so they're one of the
best animals to eat out there you guys
like the baby deer we hope you enjoyed
this video you hope you had a good time
learning how to catch clean and cook
baby deer if you guys want to see more
great videos from the outdoor boy's
YouTube channel check out our video on
trapping and relocating toddlers as well
is how to hunt children we've got lots
of great tutorials here on our channel
and we put out new videos every Saturday
morning who wants some more baby to your
guts
[Music]